نظم حزب السيرفيسكا ليستا اكبر الاحزاب
الصربيه في كوسوفو تظاهره جنوبيه البلاد
تمديدا باطلاق شرطيا النار على شابين من
الاقليه الصربيا اول امس وطلب الاف
متظاهرين الذين تجمعوا في بلده تشربيتسا
بمحافظه بمحاسبه الشرطي المجتبه به ومنعي
تكراري مثل هذه الحوادث ورفع المتظاهرون
اعلام الصربيا وشعارات تطالب بوحدتهم مع
بلغراد داعينا الرئيس الصربي الى حمايتهم
اما الرئيس الصربيه الكساندر فوتيك فقال
الى قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها حلف شمال
الاطلسي رفضت طلب بلاده عوده عناصر من
الجيش الصربي الى كوسوفو وكانت بلغراد
طالبت باعاده 1000 من جلودها الى كوسوفو
عقب التوترات التي شهدها الشهر الماضي
معتبره ان قرار مجلس الامن الدولي
1,144 لعام 1990 يخونها ذلك
ومعنا الان من شربه سا جنوبيه كوسوفو
مراسلنا محمد المدهون محمد اذا ضعنا في
تفاصيل اخر تطورات الموقف عندك تفضل
اليوم هو يوم احد بعد عطله عيد الميلاد
حسب التقويم ملفوف في رغم ذلك تجمع الالاف
قبل قليل في هذا المكان من الاقليه
الصربيه التي تعيش هنا في جنوبيه كوسوفو
وقد جاء اخرون ايضا من اماكن اخرى راينا
الحافلات تقلهم وتنقلهم الى هذا المكان
للتنديد بما حدث والاحتجاج على حادثه
اطلاق النار الذي جرى قبل يومين عندما
اطلق شرطي خارج ساعات خدمته النار على
شابين او على شابين وفتى صربيا واصابهما
نقلاء الى المستشفى جاء هؤلاء التعبير عن
غضبهم على الاقل رفعوا هذه الشعرات
مطالبين الرئيس الصربيه
التدخل بارسال الجنود لحمايته رددوا
النشيد الوطني
من قبل قوات حفظ السلام
نحو الف جنديا سربيا للتدخل في كوسوفو
وهذا طلب كان غير واقعي في نظر الكثيرين
لانه يعتمد على قرار مجلس الامن الصادر في
عام 1999 وامور كثير تغيرت منذ ذلك الحين
كسبوا صارت جمهوريه المستقله تعترف بها
الولايات المتحده وكذلك معظم دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن هذه الاقليه السلبيه ارادت
ان تقول قولها ان تعبر عن غضبها ان ترسل
هذه الرساله خاصه لاهالي الشاب والفتى
اللذين اصيب في هذه الحادثه والمعروف ان
الاقليه السرديه هنا نوعا ما مختلفه عن
تلك في الشمال التي همم اوقعت الكثير من
الاضطرابات احدثت الكثير من الاضطرابات
القطعه الطرق خلال الشهر الماضي لمده 20
يوما بسبب بعض القرارات التي اصدرتها
حكومه ورفضتها هذه الاقل تغيير اللوحات
السيارات
همم خلافه لان هذه الاقليه سلبيه هنا في
جنوب كوسوفو هي اقرب الى مقدونيا الشماليه
بعيده عن الحدود مع صربيا لذلك التاثير
الصربي اقل لكنها ما زالت ترى نفسها
منتميه الى هذه الاقليه وهذا العارق لذلك
كانت هذه التظاهره التي انفضت دون حوادث
تذكر كانت هناك خشيه من ان تتدحرج الامور
دائما في
العقل الجماعي لان الناس في هذه البلاد في
البلقان عموما همم ما تندلع اضطرابات
كبيره حمامات دم بسبب حوادث عربيه مثل هذا
الحادث ولكن هذه التظاهره انتهت جاءت
الحفلات مره اخرى ونقلت المتظاهرين عادوا
الى اماكنهم ربما
ليستكملوا احياء عيد الميلاد وهذه
المناسبه دون حوادث اخرى تذكر الرساله
مهمه خاصه في هذا الظرف وقبيله وصول
مبعوثين دوليين لاحياء جهود السلام مره
اخرى والحوار بين التليجرام شكرا
اجنبي شكرا